let's talk about the economy starting
with jobs we had very very strong jobs
numbers come out late last week CNBC
reports job growth totals 253 000 in
April beating expectations even as the
U.S economy slows from the standpoint of
GDP
the simple facts are non-farm payrolls
were expected at 180 000 came in at 253
000. that's great unemployment rate was
3.4 percent the estimate was 3.6 percent
this is the lowest unemployment rate
since 1969 and average hourly earnings
went up half of one percent and are now
up 4.4 percent from a year ago wages
growing faster than expected both in the
last month and in the last year a couple
of other interesting things to mention
here one is that black unemployment much
touted and discussed by Donald Trump as
one of his major accomplishments has hit
an all-time low do we care specifically
about the racial breakdown of jobs well
we care to the extent that elected
officials in Washington use it as a
political football now what does this
say in general about how the economy is
doing well we have to look at a lot of
different things when we ask how is an
economy doing an economy is not only
jobs an economy is not only stock market
and economies not only GDP or inflation
but in some total we can look at a lot
of these things for example here is a
chart of the Dow Jones Industrial
Average this is a one month chart as you
can see the Dow is up over the last
month here is a six-month chart the Dow
is up over the last six months here is a
year-to-date chart the Dow is up there
here's a one-year chart the Dow is up
there as well and here is a five-year
chart and the stock markets over longer
periods tend to go up and it is up then
as well so jobs numbers quite solid
stock market quite solid inflation
inflation now for the better part of a
year has been trickling down and down
and down with some blips where it goes
up our inflation numbers where we would
love them to be no are they dramatically
better the then when Trump left and Joe
Biden came in absolutely and then we
have GDP GDP growth was still positive
in q1 but it did slow down is this the
most exciting Dynamic and explosive
electrifying economy that we have ever
seen it is not
is this the near disaster that the right
claims the United States economy finds
itself in because of Joe Biden's
presence in the White House absolutely
not and as I've said many times before
many of these indicators only have
little bits to do with the policy from
the Oval Office and the presidency now
there are always reflexive people like
they can't help they just like vomit out
these talking points when they don't
like conceding that the economy is doing
okay because the person they didn't vote
for is in the Oval Office you will hear
things like there's jobs created because
everybody's working two jobs and that
makes the economy bad we have an
indicator of that there are not a
uniquely large number of people working
two jobs at this point in time you hear
about well it's the reason it's
happening is because stay-at-home moms
are having to go back to work because
the economy is so bad uh yet you never
want to talk about that dynamic when you
do your labor participation rate
conspiracy theory so we we hear about
all of these things year in and year out
we can find the data there is not
anything particularly alarming or
different right now about the number of
people who are out of the workforce and
went back in or the number of people
working two jobs it doesn't mean we
don't have problems wages relative to
inflation have been stagnant for a while
now that's a long-term problem it's
bigger than Biden it's bigger than Trump
it's bigger than Obama okay you get the
picture labor participation rate the
country's population has been growing
for a very long time at most times you
can say we have more people than ever
working and we have more people than
ever not working that makes it a really
popular political football to throw
around my suggestion is to zoom out look
at unemployment job creation GDP stocks
inflation meaning Consumer Price Index
wage growth and I could go on a couple
more
and then take the general temperature of
it to get a sense of where we are if you
do that it is not possible to come to
the conclusion some on the right have
come to which is that Joe Biden's
economy is a disaster putting the United
States on the brink of collapse there is
no case that can be made with data
actual data honest data that would
accurately suggest that that is the
situation right now could the economy be
better sure is the economy a disaster
right now not at all could it become one
in the future of course